First, let's look at the simple example
of scaling an image in two dimensions,
which basically means I
have an image here, and
I want to generate another image.
And in this case,
this image is twice as big.
Again, we have simple set of things here
in terms of how I want to get x prime
and y prime from x and y.
Now let's think about what
would be in the matrix M.
Basically, the way I want to do
scaling would be a simple, right?
I would just multiply each component
by a fixed scaler, and uniform scaling
would basically be when the same
scaler's applied to both x and y.
The difference, of course,
is if they're not the same,
you would get a different aspect ratio.
So let's say if I multiply the, all of
the x's by 1 I would get the same width.
But if I multiply all the y's by 2,
I would get a different height.
So though similarly, you know, that
different aspect ratio would come in.
So uniform scaling would only be when
I apply the same constant both ways.
If I apply different ones in x and
y directions,
that would actually allow me to
now have different aspect ratios.
So what does that mean in
terms of our matrix here?
Basically, that mean is now we would
replace the M matrix by nothing else but
two scalers on the diagonal, a, which
would actually impact the scaling in
the x direction, and b, which would
impact the scaling in the y direction.